there's not a single luxury house that
does not produce in India
we've recently had Beyonce in her tours
wearing a few of our outfits
high quality exclusive
and European the Hallmarks of 180
billion Euro luxury fashion industry
[Applause]
but unknown to many consumers is a
closely guarded Secret
countries like India are often at the
heart of what's considered European
luxury fashion
for decades luxury fashion houses
obscured their business ties to
developing nations like India or Vietnam
where labor is cheap and hard to find
handicraft skills plentiful
even if you produce in Europe at the end
the manufacturing the reality of that
business is done in India
fashion Executives have long seen labels
saying made in France or made in Italy
as key to hire profits
they worry about Western consumer
stereotypes that question quality
there's also the Optics of sourcing
goods from places where working
conditions can be poor
but that's increasingly contested by
those fighting for transparency in how
luxury fashion credits its suppliers
we set out to investigate what's behind
a fashion label
India's contribution to luxury fashion
spans Empires
the nation's embroiders were
traditionally mostly Muslim men who had
migrated to Mumbai from rural parts of
the country
they're known by the Urdu word karigar
or artisan
embroidery has always been the
distinction between the elite the Royal
Court and the different layers of
society
even if the creation is done in Paris
even if we have iTunes in Paris doing
embroidery or in Italy or in England
India has really become the backbone of
the embroidery industry
from the 1980s luxury brands have relied
in India for much of their embroidery
today there are two kinds of textile
facilities
first export houses in safe well
ventilated facilities
second subcontractors in small factories
we're sitting in a small Factory in
central Mumbai that has completed
subcontracted orders for some of the
most established International designers
when order volumes are large Indian
embroidery export houses take orders to
subcontractors throughout the city
sometimes they work with as many as a
dozen subcontractors for a single order
this is the bottom of the supply chain
and the working conditions are often the
worst sometimes Artisans to save on rent
sleep on the factory floor after they've
completed their work for the day
India is now one of the world's largest
garment exporters with the textiles and
apparel Market worth more than 150
billion dollars in 2021.
with the country's connection to Western
luxury Brands remains secret for years
we've forgotten the past we've forgotten
the Excellence of craft the big question
in fact is to know why these luxury
brands are so hesitant in putting made
India on these products when they should
be you know Buy Low putting it made in
India
foreign
the global fashion system is built on
exploitation
it's not coincidence but by design that
most of fashion today is produced in
regions where freedom of Association is
restricted where it's difficult for
workers to exert their rights
so when it comes to obscuring supply
chains there's a myth that being
transparent is commercially sensitive
that it would harm business to be
transparent and disclose who and where
your clothes are made improved
transparency is absolutely essential to
protecting the people who make our Clues
who are often some of the most
vulnerable people in Global Supply
chains
[Music]
our investigation looked at one jacket
as a case study
the Garment embellished entirely with
delicate micro mirrors retails for
almost 43 000 Euros
and according to exporters in Mumbai it
took more than 2 000 hours Tomb Raider
in India
seamstress is estimated the peace and
underwent less than 100 hours of
stitching and finishing touches in
Europe
it carries a made in France tag
reflecting European Union regulations
that Define the country of origin as the
place where the last substantial
transformation took place not where the
bulk of labor was completed
a Dior spokesperson told Bloomberg that
even though the miracle is an
exceptional piece that showcases India's
savoir fare nevertheless it was made in
France which justifies the dedicated
Maiden label
still in March 2023 Dior became one of
the first International luxury Brands to
Showcase a collection in India saying
it's determined to promote the country's
artisanal Legacy worldwide China
international the Indian export house
that embroidered clothing for the Dior
Mumbai collection declined to comment
what we are very happy about and a
little about
[Music]
took a first step to announce its
supplier we were all kept hidden for a
long time
it has changed the way the others are
thinking putting us more forward for
recognition of our work and our
embroidery and our craftsmanship which
earlier they wanted to show maybe that
it was done in Paris or Italy now they
are happy and you know to say that this
is made this embroidery is you know done
in India India's growing importance
across Industries has made the world's
most populous nation impossible to
ignore
one recipient of this attention is
Gayatri Khanna
her company Malaya embroideries has
climbed Atop The Rings in mumbai's
highest profile export houses
he counts Versace Balman and Dolce
Gabbana is just some of her clients
today we are a 450 employee business we
are in the center in the heart of Mumbai
we have over 150 odd clients which are
amazing and we cherish Ola
collaborations
[Music]
thank you
when you talk about Made in India you
tend to celebrate
craft which has come from India at the
same time you're also celebrating the
people who are making it I think it is
also all about
how to dream together
[Music]
for many in the industry the Made in
India garment tag is Paving the way for
a younger Progressive wing of creatives
who want more fairness and transparency
in how luxury fashion credits its
suppliers
so today I feel had things I be changing
slowly changing because they cannot lie
anymore they have to acknowledge that
since the last 30 years they've been
Manufacturing in the country
Manufacturing in India
[Music]